ja und jetzt schauen wir nach Frankfurt
denn es gab heute eine breaking news er
ist kein Deutschlands peinlichster
Bürgermeister und er ist heute
zurückgetreten endlich muss man sagen
denn es ist eine ganze Pannenserie auf
die erblickt gegen ihn läuft ein
verfallen gegen vorteilsname zuletzt
Geräte auch wegen sexistischer Äußerung
mächtig in die Kritik und auch diese
peinlichen Bilder hier sind unvergessen
ja schauen wir hier auf diese Bilder das
ist Peter Feldmanns großer Auftritt bei
der Siegesfeier von Eintracht Frankfurt
Europapokalsieger die Eintracht doch der
Oberbürgermeister der Stadt sich darin
Pokal will den für sich er will sich mit
dem Pokal schmücken nimmt ihn sich und
wir sehen hier das große Erstaunen von
Mannschaftskapitän und Trainer im
Hintergrund ja doch da bin ich genug es
geht nämlich noch peinlicher absolut
kurz danach taucht nämlich dieses Video
hier auf Deutschlands peinlichster
Bürgermeister auf einem Lufthansa Flug
nach Sevilla dann nimmt er das Wort
Mikrofon ja und lässt da wirklich ein
ganz fürchterlichen Spruch los
ich habe hier eine Ansage sowohl vom
Bodenpersonal als auch hier von den
Flugbegleiterin die mich hormonell am
Anfang erstmal außer Gefecht gesetzt
haben
meine Damen ja
Spruch also jetzt ein Rückzug erst im
Januar begründen tut er das sowieso mal
rein in das offizielle Statement das ja
heute abgegeben hat er sagt ich erkläre
dass ich im Januar beantrage meine
Amtszeit zum Monatsende zu beenden und
damit möchte ich der Stadt Frankfurt ein
quälendes und teures Abwahlverfahren
ersparen und die Gelegenheit nutzen
meine Amtsgeschäfte nach nur mehr über
zehn Jahren zu einem ordentlichen
Abschluss zu bringen ich werde
eingeordnetes Haus übergeben
dennoch muss man einmal auf das gucken
was wohl am schwersten für ihn wiegt im
März hatte die Frankfurter
Staatsanwaltschaft nämlich Anklage wegen
Tatverdachts der vorteilsname erhoben
fällt man es Frau soll als Leiterin
einer Kita der Arbeiterwohlfahrt ohne
sachlichen Grund ein übertariflich das
Gehalt bezogen haben also einfach mal
ein bisschen mehr Geld außerdem soll die
Arbeiterwohlfahrt fällt man im Jahr
Kampf 2018 unterstützt haben im Gegenzug
sollte er deren Interessen angeblich
wohlwollend berücksichtigen das sind
echte No-Gos in der Politik